every bari gate away.com super ho
caricato il cazzo questa cosa ma
veramente tante erano rimasti che ci
avevano tirato fuori dal gioco quindi
incoming message
per premere intero staccato un tasto
finalmente ti stavo cercando per ora è
uguale era occupato a staccare i tasti
della tastiera fatti i cazzi tuoi
faccina felice che cazzo scritto il
testo scritto un'altra roma prova a
parte chattare questo tizio possiamo
giocare perfetto grazie molto gentile
siamo per rientrare in matrix tenetevi
pronti a me il potere wrong turno nel
turno ha sbagliato io a in un camion
dietro ma quantomeno su chi non ci avevo
pensato dai sì al finestrino proprio
dovremmo farlo proprio al finestrino
mentre guidava grazie zio sei stato
molto gentile ma esce qualcuno e mi
spara in faccia lo so già devo prendere
le bottiglie alla figlia l'ho preso l'ho
preso e la madonna un fucile non ho è
mio questo mai capito giro a [ __ ]
grazie a kiev è il colletto
che peccato ragazzi cè un fucile
d'assalto cena figata e stata la cosa
più [ __ ] della terra dei crack system
dargli una lezione hanno usato il cra
cra bravi che usate il crac altro che
mamma complimenti in una roba dove che
sono questi calciatori
loro erano preparati erano preparati a o
cazzo e vabbè che cazzo sono rambo sì
certo c'è che aumenti qualcuno so una
nucleare magari sono nella completa
merda merda
no no no no no no no no grazie
minchia un po di più mamma mamma ma
donna che accetti che strage oddio cosa
ho mai chiesto il gioco regatano fuori
da prima come sono riuscito a uscire
senza che vuoi un achievement per questo
va beh mi suicido suicidi film fest a
crono no no tu non raccogli un cazzo di
non hai capito lo vedi questo braccio
non era una gamba non lo so grazie molto
gentile che hai raccolto meno dai adesso
molto grazie molto grazie molto grazie a
caschetto il faccino zio dei warrant the
only one non erano i soli
qualcuno sta usando il nostro club no
non possono usare il nostro claque al
massimo ci ruba la bamba noi sappiamo
cosa sta succedendo a questo si fa
veramente di truck recarmi delle cose
disconnessione oddio oddio
oddio che è successo ma di fatto ci sono
se interruzioni che non capisco fallo
volare
usa zio non volevo che volassi giu mi
dispiace però sentiti i propri e chi
masseti spinto un po giù guardava giu
bravo mitiche volo compreso o fino amica
mezz'ora per prender su dizione perfetto
ancora che ci stanno ci siamo ragazzi
chiave eccoli 129 merda l'ho mancato
va beh sì certo
ci mancava solo questo prendi la tazzina
bravo lanciani a segnalarmi qualcosa da
lanciare vi prego sono ammazzati da soli
che culo
sorridi e botte in faccia perfetto
ragazzi non fate domande perché non ho
idea di come abbia fatto a far suo
livello però back door operation bene
controllare un attimino che tempo fa
fuori a questo qua in perfetto questo è
il tempo la storta zio spaccati guarda
che il mio piede di porco e più bello e
guarda qua te lo faccio vedere da vicino
perfetto che bello vero grazie molto
gentile quella e mia con la mia grassi
1600 il verbano si o no vabbè dai allora
piscia tutto rispetto nerd ha preso la
trama ci azione
basta basta voglio 2 dove obama con le
mie medaglie dove cazzo è molto pure
quella posto è vabbè lo so schivato non
fare la signorina zio che non sei una
signorina xhafaj cosa fai con quel pugno
che c'è un pizzico di super hot siamo
riusciti a fare anche sta diventando
incasinato e ragga elevator miglia su un
ascensore
grazie grazie grazie grazie grazie molto
gentile grazie grazie al perfetto c'è
qualcuno fuori
sì ma stai calmo lo prende la pistola
perfetto questo e tuo zio
e vabbè invita anche mia nonna se vuoi
ricca [ __ ] sì non mi ha preso è un
[ __ ] meno male che un [ __ ] sai
che un [ __ ] tuo amico questa moda di
entrare nei muri picchiate originali
pure voi bra zio c'è una gamba che cade
prendi al volo è mai mancata credimi
vabbè prendi questo un pugnetto in
faccia luoghi perfetto super of you
don't simpson
sembra che tu non capisca andiamo a
farci un giretto 23 o il giretto lo
faccio solo decido io chi sei tu che
parli sedia vabbè lasciamo perdere la
sedia questo dovrebbe sembrati familiare
manco buca fa attenzione devi
riconoscere questo posto
questo casa tua casa tua casa ho capito
ho capito ma tu sai che è reale questo
reale è reale e reale ho capito
tutto qui è reale mi hai rotto il cazzo
cazzo cazzo capra capra capra capra e la
tua finestra quella laggiù puoi vedere
se stesso dentro
dai un'occhiata cosa disconnect in mano
cazzo volevo andare a vedermi ok siamo
in un museo che figo scalata zio devo
darti un pugno in faccia pro credimi che
non era mia intenzione l'effetto sta
diventando una bomba sto gioco ragazzi
più vado avanti più in casinò la spalla
nani già cazzo o ritrovata ciao zio
saluta ecco quella quella con quella ci
giochiamo a calcio e tinia la parte non
gioca non mettetevi contro il ninja
evitargli oppure il panino vi siete
ammazzati da soli mentre facevo il
[ __ ] guardati alle spalle
grazie magari avvertitemi 14 ore più
tardi la prossima volta se avete voglia
e se no vabbè comunque ragazzi a parte
il fatto che non è servito un cazzo
d'avvertimento se non ci si siede così
seduto composto da meno male che ci sono
gli oggetti sto museo perché sono sta
minkia ok ok perfetto sono morti tutti
tramite tranne te tranne te tranne ma a
[ __ ] watcher mette a posto
vi siete uccisi tra di voi perfetto su
chi ha detto perché mi disconnetta di 5
secondi che palle 610 che cazzo vuoi
alle 6 10 disconnette e io mi riconnesso
tutta chieda un
[Musica]
alghero cazzo merda dove i tecno solo io
ho potuto alla spalla ecco bravo metti
la testa nella sedia cosa fa no no è la
mia spada [ __ ] guardano e si usa
così perfetto studio della [ __ ] 2 ma
vieni qua via piatti l'iniqua bravo in
tutto questo non è riuscito a prendermi
era che non vorrei dirlo detto no no no
non dove l'ha visto grazie mi chiamerà
lasciata proprio sul corrimano grazie
mille chi è rimasto uno perfetto riga
qualcosa mi dice che la vinco io questa
però non ne sono sicuro è per sicurezza
facciamo di fare un po di corsa pazza
costes car e 124 bravo zio hai vinto ti
regala una pistola e ci regala pure sto
fucile il regalo presto fa la guarda che
bella è già morto sorta [ __ ] pronto
ne sto chiamando dal nuovo iphone 6
ragazzi aspettano ma questo non è un
iphone 6 questo non è un iphone
affanculo mai venduto l'iphone sbagliato
[ __ ] adesso dobbiamo andare a letto
storia vendicarci di brutto non stara
quello non era eccoli qua udine che fate
gli incazzati perché il telefono era
sbagliato ragazzi non avete venduto
iphone nokia se fosse stato un vero
nokia avrebbe demolito qualsiasi cosa mi
scusi buon uomo sa dove per caso trovo
il bagno
gentile grazie c'era il meeting ma come
quelli della apple che stanno
complottando per vendermi telefono
sbagliato franchi eccolo qua e zio
guarda che video che ha nella bella che
già scarso questa non è una
videochiamata cominceranno a lanciare
delle cose sì che non siano per anni i
[ __ ] cazzo
madonna si ho vinto ho iniziato a
lanciare cose ho vinto hanno vinto luca
cosa fa il prendi fucile guardo prende
qua e qua qua prendi lo prendi lo prendi
lo que tu perfetto cazzo fai stretching
prendi il fucile bravo adesso lo uso io
però modo di dire o aree directing
adesso non è disconnect in migrazione
dell'host in corso cioè il disco ma
basta zio e che pall
ti abbiamo detto di uscire sente zio non
escono anche se no dice mia madre
vieni dentro in che senso e ora di
pagare
no no la bolletta e stesso ti aspetta
devo andare a vedere me stesso mentre
gioco oddio minchia che trip ragazza
sono io questo amacio loculo swift cazzo
dirlo prima
oh mio dio no che figo ovviamente io sto
giocando un videogioco si però perché
c'è la tastiera sulle ginocchia e una
cosa troppo gay ma come disconnetti te
stesso devo darmi una obbedisci devo
darmi da unatras tirata in faccia e per
ragazzi la tastiera è uguale identica la
mia non lo so perché ma vi è ora di
disconnettersi dal gioco madonna
non c'ero io non c'ero grazie a dio non
c'ero ho creduto fortemente di esserci
il bello ragazze che sono vestito pure
di rosso cazzo è uguale come è stato a
testa è moment act capsule molli hai
detto che saresti uscito ma non l'hai
fatto
questo non è un giocattolo sai che
possiamo ucciderti con le tue stesse ma
che cosa vuoi da me
ora tu uscirai dal gioco e per dio
dimentica che cosa è successo la tua
storia finisce qui chat conclusa devo
tornare nel gioco ragazzi non posso lo
vedi allora deve uscire ragazzi se non
si incazzano deve uscire approviamo ci
ricorda noi che osserviamo e calciato
gioco è che lasciato veramente il gioco
bene ragazzi credo che la demo sia
finita qua quindi ragazzi questo era il
suv o spero che vi sia piaciuto questo
era soltanto la beta di super 8
ringrazio ancora i creatori del gioco
per avermi dato la possibilità di
giocarlo in beta perché ancora non è
uscito pd ragazzi super8 finisce qua
finchè non esce un gioco completo e se
vi è piaciuta la serie lasciato mi
piaccione mi piaccio ciò nel video anche
la pagina di facebook e co meneghino
tradizione servirsi di scrittrici perché
ho paura di essere osservato ragazzi
perché mi sento in soggezione
va beh sono stato il sistemi non ci
vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]